it's disturbing new data and it shows 42
migrants on the terror watch list have
been arrested trying to enter our
country illegally since joe biden took
office those numbers released after a
request from congressman chip roy to the
department of homeland security
congressman chip roy joins us now good
morning to you congressman
good morning good morning i know you
tweeted out on tuesday you're slamming
joe biden and mayorkis for blaming them
for the 42 people with terrorist ties
sneaking into our country and you're
also questioning something we've all
asked on the curvy couch how many more
did sneak in that we didn't catch
tell us more about that what led to that
and then what led to the investigation
trying to find out the true numbers
sure well angel you're asking the
question that every american is asking
right now and that jen saki is just
dismissing and look first a little shout
out to bill milligan who's out there
doing such great reporting and last week
he put out that he had seen something
like 23 or gotten some information that
there were 23. well we got a letter that
same day or week
we sent a letter to dhs last august okay
so it took eight months and my office
finally got a response back eight months
later for the detailed questions we had
asked one of which they answered
indicating that there were 42
individuals arrested with known uh ties
to uh you know terrorists had that
they're on the terror watch list and so
that's a real problem that you can serve
most americans but the thing is is gen
saki dismisses that and says well that's
point zero zero zero x of the encounters
well hold on a second jinsaki can't tell
us how many people have come into our
country who are known godaways right we
know from the intelligence and that what
we're looking at and and the information
we get from border patrol agents that
there's been some five hundred thousand
six hundred thousand maybe even seven
hundred thousand known got aways meaning
people we don't even know who they are
and they're the worst actors who come
into the united states but in addition
to the 42 individuals on the terror
watch list there are 480 that were
stopped with known gang affiliations now
again translate those numbers to the 500
000 or more gotaways the number of
people who are coming in on a daily
basis some 2 000 who come across our
border every day that the border patrol
agents can't even get to and what's
really disturbing about this is the
extent to which secretary mayorkas the
president himself and jen saki just
dismissed this as if we shouldn't care
what's happening at our border but god
bless bill malugen for uh seeking the
facts and and we're trying to do the
same thing in congress yeah i think that
23 number was up until december but then
now that we're into april it's 42. and
yeah you're right we don't know who
these people are and when jinsaki says
it's point zero zero x percent of how
many are coming over all it takes is one
that's right no that's the exact that's
that's the truth right we saw that
obviously with the tragedy in new york
in 2001 on 9 11 uh it took what 19 right
and these were visa overstays now we've
got people that we know to be dangerous
individuals and it's not just the terror
watch list right look that 480
affiliation with gangs the number of
people coming in with massive criminal
histories who come in and we see the
crimes that are committed in the united
states talk to the ranchers in south
texas talk to the americans who are
getting impacted every single day by
criminal activity and dangerous
individuals because the administration
refuses to secure the border and it's on
them and it's purposeful we're in the
middle of inflation highest in what 40
years and now we're we're paying for
them 338 million on infrastructure 166
million on health care 98 million on
utilities and food 36 million on
transportation by airplane some of those
secret flights 12 million on
transportation by by vehicle cbp
and look at the encounters in march the
highest in a very long time 221 303
we're probably going to see higher
numbers in april because it's getting
warmer and then in may when title 42
ends what can we expect
well that's the exact question to ask
right when we ask uh experts on the
border and you know brandon judd and the
people that i know and their friends
that i talk to regularly uh we're
looking at numbers that could explode
from the current seven thousand eight
thousand a day up to fifteen thousand
maybe even more a day if they repeal or
stop enforcing title 42 now we've got a
way to solve that problem and that's if
the department of homeland security will
actually continue to enforce title 42
and frankly go further and actually turn
people away at the border the american
people are tired of this like i talk to
texans every day i'm in in texas right
now in the district i represent austin
san antonio and met with a bunch of
people yesterday they want our borders
secured they want us to stop spending
money we don't have and they want to get
the federal government out of the way
and interfering with mandates um and and
telling them what to do and living their
lives so it's a simple prescription for
the future of our country and that's why
we're going to have a good november for
republicans congressman thanks for
joining us
god bless ainsley hi i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now